right look at you thank you
[Applause]
okay
thank back look I don't know if you got
the memo but um there's been a change in
the program we're freaking out about
Ebola again I don't be in the middle of
the week we stopped but now we started
again because Ebola I know if you heard
this has arrived in New York City and I
say if it can make it there it can make
it anywhere start spreading the plague
I'd sing more of that but we'd have to
pay um now I am so not worried about
this because you know what I know how
this disease spreads and New Yorkers her
famous for not taking [ __ ] from anybody
you know now this this patient who has
it he was a doctor uh he is a doctor
with Doctors Without Borders he was in
Africa which is that's an admirable
thing to do he has my utmost respect for
doing that but he comes back to New York
knowing he was just there working with
Ebola patients he rides three subways
he took an uber taxi he jogs through the
park and he goes bowling can't anybody
just relax in this city what what is it
with this disease between him going
bowling and dr. Nancy's not even going
out for food and the lady got on a
cruise ship or the hill that went to
Cleveland
this is the only disease it makes you
want a [ __ ] vomit and mingle honestly I
think you put a distended we live in a
world where every imaginable interaction
can be done online or with the touch of
a button or remotely and somehow the
free bulk of victim comes back from
Africa with an uncontrollable urge to
join an improv class guy goes bowling oh
my god I know they've shut down the
bowling alley Rose went well they should
there's one thing you don't want to do
is to stick your finger in a bowl of
patients balls that is the worst we know
that so well
the other big story this week terror has
a new face much like Renee Zellweger and
ladies
you're right too far too soon too far
and too soon
no no it's Canadian terrorism there was
it I'm sure you saw this an attack on
the Canadian Parliament the the shooter
we know now was a convert to well I
don't to be called a bigot so I'll just
say a religion we I don't know which one
I'm that's how much of a liberal I am
because it's equally likely could be any
religion I you know what I think it was
the Amish I think the guy was Amish no
he was he he was a guy who was a
jihadist the Muslim jihadist and the
Canadian jihadist Wow
the authorities are calling him vanilla
Isis
and that's I mean I I love Canada I I
feel that everybody up there is on edge
now Rob Ford today said I get I guess I
picked the wrong week to quit smoking
crack i but here's here's what I don't
get about this the attacker made known
his wish to go join Isis in Syria and
the government took away his passport we
do the same thing I don't get it
how about this if a guy a violent
religious nut says he wants to go to
Syria
let him here's a plane ticket your
connection is in Liberia good luck
[Applause]
and Rayleigh Canada if we're gonna start
confiscating passports couldn't we strut
with Bieber uh but you know never to be
outdone with mayhem America the country
of mayhem we had a school shooting today
and also this week another another White
House fence jumper did you see that this
time Obama was home for it and when he
when he saw the guy running across the
right White House lawn toward the White
House he said to the Secret Service oh
don't stop him yet at least that's one
person not trying to distance himself
from me did you see did you see the
president this week voting in Chicago he
was doing his early voting this was a
funny scene because he was next to this
woman who was also voting and the
woman's boyfriend walks by and says mr.
president don't touch my girlfriend
that's weird I mean they didn't say that
to Clinton and he was touching your
girlfriend but how do you know Obama
always coolly said to the guy if you
like the girlfriend you have you can
keep the girlfriend yeah